Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Un petit barbeuc, ça vous dit ?
Il y a des brochettes, de la viande, du poisson,
des saucisses, des merguez, des fruits
et des légumes, des steaks de soja
et même des mouches et des guêpes.
Mais au fait, le barbecue,
est ce vraiment bon pour la santé ?
Certains en doutent.
On en parle tout de suite.
Et croyez-moi, ça va chauffer.
Ben moi, je suis prêt.
Vous l'avez peut-être déjà entendu dire,
"barbecue" viendrait d'une vieille expression française
"barbe au cul" ou "barbe à queue".
Il s'agit d'une pratique moyenâgeuse
qui consistait à embrocher
une chèvre pour la faire cuire à la broche
au dessus des braises.
La broche était enfilée de la barbe à la queue.
Les Anglais qui prononçaient mal le français,
auraient transformé "barbe à queue" en "barbecue".
Sauf que non.
C'est une légende.
Une légende un peu fumeuse quand même.
En réalité,
le mot barbecue viendrait de l'arawak,
la langue des Taïnos,
un ancien du peuple amérindien
qui vivait dans les Caraïbes
à la fin du XVᵉ siècle,
lorsque les Espagnols colonisent la région,
ils y découvrent un nouveau mode de cuisson.
Des branchages qui servent de support à la viande placée au-dessus des braises.
Les Indiens l'appellent "barbacoa"
Les Espagnols, conquis, adorent,
Boh, un peu tiré par les cheveux.
Peut-être, mais la méthode est ingénieuse.
La viande est surélevée, ce qui évite
qu'elle soit dévorée par les animaux.
En prime,
la fumée tient les insectes à distance,
ce qui permet une meilleure conservation de la viande.
Importé en Europe et adopté par les Anglais.
Ce barbacoa serait devenu, avec le temps et avec l'accent, le barbecue.
Au XIXᵉ siècle, il envahit l'Amérique
grâce à la conquête de l'Ouest.
Il permet aux migrants
de se nourrir en plein air
durant leur long périple vers la Californie.
Mais il faut attendre
la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
pour que le barbecue
entre dans les foyers américains.
Dans les années 1950,
il devient même l'un des symboles de l'American way of life.
Et il finit par envahir le monde.
Et pas que les aires de pique-nique.
Le livre des records également,
comme une entreprise américaine
qui détient la palme du barbecue
le plus cher du monde
environ 150000€.
Il faut dire que ce magnifique
objet est plaqué or.
Depuis quinze ans,
deux pays se disputent par ailleurs
le record du plus grand barbecue du monde.
Il s'agit de l'Argentine et de son voisin
l'Uruguay, tenant du titre depuis 2017.
À Minas une petite ville du sud du pays.
Plus de 200 personnes ont désossé
et placé
sur des grilles
les morceaux d'une centaine de vaches.
Au total, près de seize tonnes de viande.
La performance a nécessité
60 tonnes de bois
et une centaine de cuisiniers
qui se sont relayés pendant 14 h pour
surveiller la cuisson.
A mon avis, les Argentins n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot.
Il faut dire que là bas, on ne plaisante
pas, non pas avec le barbecue,
mais l'asado
Et nous, tu crois qu'on plaisante ?
En France, on ne détient pas de record.
Mais le barbeuc, comme on dit,
c'est aussi du sérieux.
Plus de 60% des foyers en sont équipés.
D'ailleurs,
chaque année, au mois de septembre,
se déroule aux Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer
le championnat de France de barbecue.
Plus de 80 équipes
viennent de toute la France
pour se disputer
le titre du barbecue le plus succulent.
Il y en a pour tous les goûts :
viandes, poissons, fruits, légumes.
Plats de résistance
et desserts. Eh, on s'inscrit ?
Je suis chaud comme la braise.
Mais auparavant,
j'ai encore quelques infos sur le gril.
On l'a dit,
le barbecue est une méthode de cuisson
astucieuse,
découverte chez les Indiens d'Amérique.
Mais ils ne l'ont pas inventé.
Cette méthode
de cuisson est beaucoup plus ancienne.
Elle date de la préhistoire.
Les plus vieilles traces
sont estimées à 1,5 million d'années.
Elles ont été identifiées en 2019
sur un site
archéologique
de la région de Koobi Fora, au Kenya.
La découverte de ce barbecue préhistorique
a bouleversé nos connaissances.
Elle a permis de repousser
d'un million d'années
les premières traces d'usages
contrôlés du feu par les Hommes.
Jusque-là,
on estimait que notre lointain cousin Homo erectus
avait commencé à maîtriser le feu
il y a 500000 ans.
Euh...
Et ça change quoi ?
Eh bien, ça renforce l'hypothèse
que l'usage du barbecue
a eu une influence majeure
sur l'évolution biologique du genre Homo.
Le recours à la cuisson a en effet
permis de rendre la viande plus tendre.
Cela a facilité la mastication
et donc la digestion des aliments.
Le corps faisant moins d'efforts
pour digérer,
il a pu utiliser cette énergie
au profit de nouvelles compétences.
Le barbecue aurait également entraîné
une modification du régime alimentaire
de nos ancêtres.
Il leur a permis de consommer
certains légumes
très difficiles à digérer crus
comme le blé, l'orge,
les racines, les tubercules.
Cette nouvelle richesse alimentaire
aurait favorisé
l'évolution du cerveau des hominidés.
Le barbecue nous a rendu intelligent.
Il a fait mieux que ça.
Il a contribué à l'augmentation
de notre espérance de vie.
Cuire la viande a permis d'éliminer
des parasites
qui étaient vecteurs
de maladies mortelles.
Bon, ce n'est pas tout.
Je commence à avoir une petite faim
Ça chauffe bien.
Quand on parle de barbecue.
Une question revient souvent.
Est-ce dangereux pour notre santé ?
En effet, la cuisson au gril favoriserait
l'apparition de certains cancers.
Cette crainte n'est pas injustifiée,
mais vous allez le voir
utilisé correctement ce mode de cuisson
ne présente aucun risque.
Alors c'est vrai.
Plusieurs études ont démontré
que lorsque la viande et le poisson
sont cuits à feu vif, ils produisent
de nouveaux composés chimiques
sous forme de fumées notamment.
Il s'agit des amines hétérocycliques (HCA)
et des hydrocarbures aromatiques polycycliques (HAP)
Alors là, il m'a perdu.
dit comme ça, c'est un peu compliqué.
Ce qu'il
faut retenir, c'est que ces substances
sont potentiellement cancérogènes en cas
d'ingestion ou d'inhalation.
Pour vous donner une idée, on les retrouve
également dans la fumée de cigarette.
Mais rassurez-vous,
en respectant certaines règles de cuisson,
on peut facilement minimiser les risques.
Première précaution à prendre.
Vos aliments doivent être placés
à la bonne hauteur.
Là, par exemple, la grille est trop basse,
trop proche des braises.
Je vais la rehausser.
Elle doit au minimum
se trouver à dix centimètres des braises.
De cette manière, la viande ne sera jamais
en contact avec les flammes.
Ce sont elles qui carbonisent
la nourriture.
Consommés trop fréquemment
ou sur une longue période,
les aliments carbonisés augmentent
sensiblement les risques de cancer.
Et bien sûr, n'hésitez pas à cuisiner
poisson, des légumes ou des fruits au barbecue
Ils sont excellents, cuits
sur la braise.
Ouh ! Je me suis brûlé.
Ah oui, le feu, ça brûle
C'est le plus grand danger avec le barbecue.
C'est même un classique de l'été.
Environ 200 brûlures graves sont recensées
chaque année par le Ministère de la Santé.
Il fait chaud, on est torse nu.
Un moment d'inattention et hop,
c'est l'accident bête.
Allo, les pompiers ?
Je vous rassure. La plupart des brûlures
sont superficielles.
Il convient toutefois
de respecter quelques consignes
n'utilisez jamais d'alcool à brûler
pour démarrer votre feu.
Les projections d'alcool enflammé sont
responsables de la plupart des accidents.
Préférez un allume feu traditionnel.
Ayez également toujours à portée
de main
de l'eau et du sable pour éteindre le feu si nécessaire
et surtout éloignez
les enfants du barbecue.
Ils représentent 15% des victimes.
À cause de leur petite taille,
ils sont à peu près à la hauteur du feu.
Bon, et quand est-ce qu'on mange ?
Parce que les bonnes paroles,
ça nourrit pas ?
Ça va.
Il n'y a pas le feu. À ce propos.
On allume pas un barbecue n'importe où.
Les communes et les départements
les interdisent dans les zones boisées.
Heureusement.
Alors, le plus sûr, me direz-vous,
c'est de s'installer sur son balcon
ou sur sa terrasse.
Sauf que ce n'est pas aussi simple.
Le règlement intérieur
de votre copropriété peut l'interdire.
Idem pour le jardin
en période de sécheresse.
Certaines municipalités interdisent
les barbecues par arrêté municipal.
Mais non !?
Mais alors, il nous reste quoi ?
Les parcs publics ?
C'est la dernière chose à faire.
À Paris, par exemple,
il est formellement interdit
d'allumer un feu dans un lieu public.
Vous vous exposeriez à une amende
qui peut aller jusqu'à 127€.
Ça fait cher la saucisse.
Eh, chez moi. J'ai vérifié.
C'est autorisé.
Bon, on fait un petit barbeuc. Tu viens ?
Je peux être me laisser tenter
Ah ! Une bonne petite brochette.
Et voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
N'oubliez pas l'essentiel cet été,
c'est de vous abonner.
Si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
votre barbecue n'en sera que meilleur.
Et puis, si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à liker.
Ça me fera chaud au cœur.
Bon, il est temps de nous quitter.
Je vous laisse méditer
sur cette citation de Coluche :
Le barbecue, en gros, c'est un appareil qui permet de
manger des saucisses pratiquement crues,
mais avec le bout
des doigts bien cuits.